パラニャーナの後でパラニャーナいくつか二つ三つぐらい生まれて
それから普通の心に戻るんです
ごく普通の心に戻るんです
もう聖者なんです 煩悩がなくなっちゃったんです
ですから 一人の人に輪廻の中で解脱するまで
このマッガチッタというのは四つしか生まれません
それも一回きり 煩悩は二度と殺せませんだからね
だから四回で殺すんだから
煩悩は だから四つしか生まれません
他は瞑想するとたまたま生まれてきます
それでこのパラニャーナ
パルチッタから立ち上がるでしょ
普通の心に 立ち上がったらどんな感想かというと
なんか巨大な山火事は瞬間に消えたような感じ
なんかものすごくこのもうすっごいずっと永久的に
ものすごい勢いでもう自分のこの体の中で
心の中ですっごく何か戦争みたいな
第三世界戦争みたいな
もう激しいことが来て
もう瞬時にパッと消えたというような
なんか消えた 終わった
基本そういうふうな なんとなくすごいそういう感じなんですね
感傷としては それで本当の今まで探していた安らぎではなくて
安定感ではなくて それは安定感です
それで安定するんです
安心するんです 山火事が消えた
だからその安らぎを得るためにはかなり苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
精神的な やっぱり世間的な気持ち
価値観 全部捨てなくちゃいけないんです
捨てられるまでは大変ですけど
今までの全ての希望を捨てなくちゃいけない
かすかな希望もあったらできません
全部すべてもう もう死ぬ覚悟になった瞬間で
もう智慧が生まれてきて
もう永久的な安心という心がそれで生まれちゃうんです
それから悟った後から
もう単なる心が流れていくだけで
その場その場で全然もう平気なんですね
ただ流れてるだけで 人が何か言ったら
それには言い返しは それはそれだけのことです
お腹が空いたら何かご飯を取って食べるし
それ以上何のことなく死ぬまでただ流れてる
それは最終的に悟った人の場合はね
だから預流果に悟った人の場合は
一旦涅槃は体験するんだけど
まだまだ自分の心にまたいくつか残っているんじゃないかと
もっと足らないんではないかと
いろいろ失敗してるんではないかという
このもっとやらなくちゃという気持ちはきちんと入っちゃうんですね
で それから三十七番書いてる頁のパッチレッカーナージャン
で あの 一応自分の心に何が起きたかと
これ大変な出来事なんです
あっという間の出来事なんですけど
大変な出来事なんですね
ですから どうせどんな瞑想の場合もパッチレッカーの後観察は必要なんですね
それで後観察するんですね
それを観察すると言うんですね
どうなったかと 後観察のことは説明しましたからね
一応その心が 瞬間の心が生まれた後で
なんかどうなったかと
だいたいなんか消えちゃうんじゃないかなと
全部というふうな もう火事が消えちゃうんではないかという感じが生まれてくる
これで私はどうなったんでしょうかと
これ全部悟ったというんですか？とかね
自分でやっぱり観察するんですね
まあなんとなくうまくいったみたいですけど
やっぱりそれでも私にはこういうこういうことがあるんじゃないかなと
でも私はこういうことはしっかりもう知ってるんだと
いわゆるなくなった煩悩ですね
実体はないんだと 有身見とそれから戒禁取と
それから疑いですね 疑い
そういうのは絶対ないんだけど
やっぱりちょっと怒りとかね
欲とかまだまだあるんじゃないかなと
もうちょっと頑張らないとまだ怒りなんか消えませんよというふうになりますね
ですから その瞑想の後で
ほんのちょっと まあちょっと時間観察するんですよ
それを教えてあげなくたってヴィパッサナーの人は
それでだいたい終わり
まあ一応ほんのちょっとまた不満があるだろうと思って読んでみますけど
で まあ一応あの三百三ページに解脱のいろいろ種類があるんです
で そんなこの種類とかなんとか言っちゃうと
普通の人々はかなり混乱しますけど
どちらの方が偉いですかとかね
それは俗人の考え方で
こんな単なる言葉なんですね
そこでタッタ アナッターヌパッサナ アッター ビニウェーサン ムンチェティ スンニャターヌパッサナー ナーマ ヴィモッカ ムカンホーティタ
スンニャター ヴィモッカ
空解脱 このアナッターヌパッサナ
アナッタっていうのは無我
無我観察 無我を観察して
推察ですね 観察という
無我を推察すると スンニャタ
空解脱というんです 空っていうのはシュンニャニャ・フーですね
で それは難しいことじゃないんです
九つのヴィパッサナーの智慧の説明ありましたね
それは最終的なステージなんです
その九つの智慧で全て弾けているんだ
弾けているんだというと
自分がこのニッビダーというか
この単相を見るでしょうに
この単相っていうのはある角度で実体がないんだと
結局は 結局はドゥッカではないかと
結局全て無常ではないかと
とにかくそうやって自分で探求
見ますね 単所を見ると何かラベリングするんです
ラベリングというよりは
わざとラベリングではなく
自分の経験だからね やっぱり実体がないね
どちらにもと というのは無我なんですね
今まで私がいるいるんだと見られるものもあるんだと思ってたんだけど
全部弾けて弾けていくんだから
実体がないんだと思ったらアナイ
ヴィパッサナーなんですね
それで実体がないんだと言って
果敢性が生まれてきて
果敢性というか 単相が見えてきて
それから怨霊が嫌になってきてしまって
それから脱欲が生まれてきて
解脱したいんだと それからさらに観察していっちゃうと
やっぱり実体がないんだ
ないんだという感じで
実体がないんだとは観察しませんよじゃなくて
ただ普通に観察していくんです
観察しちゃうとウペッカーが生まれてくるんですね
ヴィパッサナー ウペッカー
サンカー ウペッカー ニャーナ
諸行に対する者が生まれてきて
次の瞬間に悟りの心が生まれるんです
その悟りにちょっとラベルを貼りたければズンニャーという目と言うんです
次にアニッチャー ヴィパッサナーなんですね
それは何？目か  2番目
もしすべてのものは弾けていくんだ
弾けていくんだという観察した人にとっては
この弾ける 弾けていく過程を見ていると
前にあったものを変わって新しいものが生まれた
それ変わってまた違うものが生まれたか
それ変わってまた違うもの生まれてきたんだという
この変化見えちゃうんですね
変わっていくんだ 変わっていくんだと
実体がないんだ 実体じゃない
変わったんだ またそれ変わったんだ
またそれまた変わったんだと
まあ変わるばっかしじゃないかと
1つもないんだということになっちゃうんですね
変わる変わるっていうことは
無常 無常ということなんですね
だから観察しているどんなサンカーラでもどんな現象でもいいんだけど
自分にこれ変わってるということで
ピンなんて言いますか
ピンとくるんですね 心に
前にあった現象が変わって
今の現象が出て それ変わって次の現象が出てくるんだと
だから変わってという言葉は
たったそれだけのことで変わるっていうこと
別に実体 実体という同じことなんですけど
実体だったら変わらないんだから
だから変わるんだ 変わるんだということで
またウペッカーが生まれてくるならば
次に悟るでしょ？次の心で
その風に悟った人の悟りについてはアニミッテー
ヴィモッケー 無常 無常解脱かな
無常解脱なんとかいうみたいですね
無常 こちらで使ってる言葉ではなくて
無常解脱です そこでブッダだよと見ると空しいだよと
アッパね ヴィモッケーってアッパね
人は こっちは無願 無願か無限かわかりません
無願 垂涎と書いているところで無願解脱なんですね
ああ 願うことはないという意味で願うべきものはない
ですから このすべてのものはもう弾けていくんだ
弾けていくんだというレベルで
という智慧のレベルでドッカだよと
結局はドッカっていうのは空しいだよと
まあ弾けていくんだから
というふうなことで ドゥッカにいわゆる頼らなくてもいいんだと
価値観はないんだと 瞬間の現象が消えちゃう
それなんで価値観入れるんですかね？何もない
次の瞬間で他のものが生まれてくるんだから
そういうふうな気持ちはドゥッカの智慧なんですね
ドゥッカっていうのは空しいっていう意味ですね
そういうふうに悟る人の悟りにはアッパニヒトリモッカというふうに
このヴィモッカ 解脱に対してつの言葉が経典に使っているんです
経典では だからといって解脱の種類がありますよということではなくて
これは俗世間にいる人はどんなアスペクト
どんな側面を見て気づいたかということなんです
例えば東京に入る道路が地方から東京に入る道路がつ
例えばつぐらいあるとする
とにかく首都高速道路に入らなくちゃいけないと
どこから入ったっていいでしょうね
首都に入れば でも入った場所によって何か変わるんですか？何も変わりません
あんたはあっちから入ったんだから
もう東京は見られませんよとかはないんでしょうし
ですから 無常見諦でも苦見諦でも無我見諦でも解脱すればいいんです
こちらでは解脱にはそういう分け方しないです
アビダンマテキスト このテキストでは分け方しないで
このすべてこの観察の次元だから
解脱には関係ないんだから
この言葉 ですから スンヤタ・ヴィモッカではなくてスンヤタ・アヌパッサナ
空随観 無常随観 無我随観と書いているんですね
こちらはちょっとまあ落ち着いて説明するんです
空随観 それから次にマッグ
道は空という解脱であると
だからドゥーカありますね
ドゥーも空ドゥー 空カと書きたがっているんですね
だからアヌパッサナ マッグ
パタ 全部つに分けてるんで
そこら辺にというのはこんなするだけで
[咳]それから四十年
三百五ページ 四十見てください
エッタパナソーターパティマッガンバーウィッタディッティヴィチキッチャーパハーネーナパヒーナーパーヤガマノーサッタカットゥパラモーソーターパーノーナマホーティ
ソーターパティ預流果という
預流道ですか それを修行した人はディッティ見と聞という
なんで回向衆入ってないんですか
見と聞という二つの煩悩はなくなるんですね
そこで彼がまだまだ輪廻するんです
預流果になっても輪廻するんだけど
墜落はしない いわゆる地獄には落ちません
餓鬼道 畜生 それから何でしたっけ？阿修羅
また誰かいるみたいですけど
三つでしょう 餓鬼 阿修羅と畜生と地獄ですね
そちらには行けません
もう絶対行かないんですね
地獄には絶対落ちません
それから人間の世界 天界
そこは回りますけど それも七回に限ると
天国にも生まれ変われるし
人間の世界で生まれ変われますけど
七回に限る 七回目では必ず悟るんですね
だからこの悟る 最終的に悟れるぐらいまだまだ均衡足らない場合は
そういう人々はこの大体天界でぐるぐる回ってるんですね
だから人間に回ったら
まあほとんど寿命は短いでしょうし
でも預流果になった人は人間に生まれたってもすぐわかるんです
その人は抜群の哲学者で
能力者で もう並の人ではないんです
だから世の中で知られてあってもなくても
それは関係ないんです
生まれつきその人の見方が違う
欲はないというかね まあ他の人と比べて欲がないし
落ち着いて生活するうち
本人にはもうあるんです
智慧は 昔瞑想してこういうことをわかったという智慧じゃないんです
物事を見ると無意味ですよと
まあそんなこと言ったって無常ですよと
人の言葉には騙されません
誘惑することはできない
すぐそういうことではないかと言われるんだから
もともとその煩悩執着はないわけで
私は加工性でなんとかなんとかなところで
こういうこういう修行でこういう位置に立ったって
そんなことまではないと思いますけどね
もっと本物なんですね
煩悩はないだけで それでサカダーガーミ
一来果になるとラーガドーサ
ラーガドーサモーハアナンタヌカ・タヌカラッタ
一来果になるとラーガドーサモーハ貪瞋痴ですね
薄くなる 弱まるためこの世に一回しか生まれ変われません
不還果に不還道修行するとカーマラーガ・ビャーパーダーナン・アナワセーサッパハーネーナ・アナーガーミナーマホーティ
貪欲瞋恚っていうのは残りなく遮断するため
この世に帰ってこないから不還という
で この世の中で生まれるためには欲と怒りが必要なんです
天界に生まれるためにも欲と怒りが必要
人間に生まれるためには欲と怒りが必要なんですね
ですから この世の中では生まれません
生まれる資格ないというか
もう脱出しているんですね
ですから もっと上の方
梵天の方に行ってしまっちゃうんですね
そちらには欲も怒りもいりませんだから
そこでアラハッタ・マッガン・バーウィッタ最終番目の瞑想するとアナワセーサキーレサッパハーネーナすべての煩悩を残りなくなくなりますから
アラハーナーマホーティ阿羅漢と言うんですよと
キーナーサワ キーナーサワっていうのは煩悩がすべてなくなったという人と言うんですよ
ローキ・アッガダッティーネーヨ
最上者である供養を受けるべき人の中
最上者であると阿羅漢という
これが そうやって四種類の覚りがあるということ
それから禅定に入る場合は
チッタ・ヴィーティ 心のヴィーティが
幹が大体全部同じなんですね
全部同じですけど ニロージ・サマーパティという特別なサマーディがあります
滅定という それはできるのは不還果と阿羅漢果になった人だけ
滅定という禅定に入ることはその二人にだけできます
他の人にはできません
まあ一応最終的に滅定って何でしょうかと説明してアビダンマを終わります
だからどんな禅定に入る場合でも
最後の心というのはパリカンマでしょ
パリカンマ心 次にウペチャーラ心
それからアヌローマという心が生まれる
それからアッパナーという心なんですね
アッパナーというのはサマーディの心
出世間 出世間心の場合はアッパナーというのは解脱の心
どっちでも次元変わる心ですね
それ禅定に入っているんだというと
このアッパナーの心は限りなく続くんですね
一時間 三時間とか 続けて最後にまた有分身が生まれて
有分身というのはバワンガだからバワンガ心が生まれて
普通のまた心に戻るんですね
だからこの流れ どんな禅定にも同じなんですね
だからアッパナーアッパナーで続けちゃうんですね
サマーディどうやって書くんですか
まあこれはサマーディですから
書けませんね 忘れた 書いてこれで
ここから まあいいだろう
あの人ぐらい学んでから
禅定に入ったっていうことは
この定の心が続けるっていうことなんですね
その場合はもう思考もないし
考え方もその同じ状態は続くんですね
第1禅定だったらその同じ状態は続く
ですからもう考えることがないんだから
どんな禅定の場合も やっぱり自分が消えたような感じがしますけど
消えたというよりはもうなんか一緒になったと
外の世界と自分の対象と自分が一緒になったという
だからそれの差がいろいろありますけどね
で そうやってこれサマーディに入る心の流れなんです
で ヴィパッサナーして悟りの方に入っても同じことで
その場合はパーリ語のアヌローマッパナアヌカレ
定と書かないでカと書くんですね
これか うん だから定の代わりにカと書くんですね
それでその心は続けるんですね
その心 カの心だけ続けるんです
それだけの差 ですから預流果になったら
ちょっと頑張って瞑想しちゃうと瞬間しか預流果の味わえませんだから涅槃を味わえませんだからね
後でもっと頑張って瞑想しちゃうと
同じ預流果のサマーディに入ってることも不可能ではないんです
大体真面目に瞑想すると預流果のサマーディに入るだけで進めないんです
またすっごい気をつけて頑張らないと一度一 like にはなりません
かなり頑張らないと で
そうやって続く これ最終的に私は滅定ニロースサマーパッティということを説明
最後の説明 ニロースサマーパッティっていうのはみんなにできるわけじゃないんです
それできるのは阿羅漢
最終的に悟った人 それから不還果になった人
その方々もサマーディの訓練もなければダメなんです
という話なんです で 預流果にじゃなくて不還果にまで悟っている
その上でサマーディの訓練もしている
あるいは悟っている 阿羅漢果までサマーディの訓練もあるとすると
滅定 滅定への入場できますと
滅ってニローダ 滅することだからね
定っていうのはサマーディ
なんか全て消えたような消えたサマーディに入るんですね
だから不思議なサマーディなんです
何も経験しない 全て消えているんだから
空の状態だから 本物の空の状態
そのリストはどのように？また同じなんですね
パーリカンマ ウパチャーラ
アヌローマ そこまで行ってサマーディが終わるでしょ
そこで何も生まれません
ニッバーナ こっち側は定と書いたんだけど
書くものはないんです
心が止まるんです ここで
アヌローマなところで不思議に心はストップなんです
何が心続くわけじゃないんです
そこで 例えばその人は一日間サマーディ状態に入りたかったならば
滅定に入れた入場したかったならば
入場に入ったということは心は止まる
止まって一日終わったところで
またここから心が始まるんです
普通の心が この心の影響的な流れが一旦切れるんですね
これ大変なことで 不還果と阿羅漢果になっている人でしかできません
ですから この生きることっていうのは大変苦しいことだから
たまたまそういう人々は入ってみるんですね
入ってみたら その時間は生きてないんです
いない 体はここにあるんだけど
かすかにでも心はなし
心なくなったっていうことは
医学的には死んだっていうことなんですね
だから我々の現代的な俗的な言葉で言えば
まあたまたま死んでみるというぐらいのものなんですね
1 日間死んでみるとかね
普通の人はできません
だから 1 日中 1 日間死んでいたら
1 日間はすべての問題から解放されてるでしょ
で それもずっとできるわけじゃないんです
それで寿命ある限り で
だからどうせ体を持ってて心を持ってても
最終的に悟ってるんだから
体ある限り生きてなくちゃいけないんですね
エネルギーがあるんだから
ですから 亡くなる瞬間ではもう涅槃に入りますから
それで終わりますけど
それは途中で亡くなる前にサマーディに入っちゃう場合は
やっぱりいろいろ決まりがあって
入定に入り 滅 滅上の入定に入ってそのまま死んじゃったということはありえないんです
これ一時停止だから だから体崩されなくなっちゃうんですね
ちょっと一旦停止しただけのことだから
ですから この日にち終わったらまた戻らなくちゃいけない
例えば明日死の予定 その人が寿命が明日で終わるとする
でも今日はそれを忘れて
今日は滅尽定に入る 滅尽定に入ったら大体 1週間ぐらいいるんですね
だから 1週間ぐらい行っちゃうと
明日どうやって死ぬんですかね
それで 1週間経ったところで
また心は生き返ってもらわないといけませんだけど
エネルギーはどこにあるんですか？エネルギーは 1 日分しかなかったんですね
そういうことでものすごくややこしくなっちゃうんですね
ややこしくなるんだから
滅尽定に入る人はまず寿命を見て
寿命のここら辺で止まるんですね
だから入定から出場しなくちゃいけないんです
出場すると心がまた回転し始めないと
亡くなるためには心はもう一回回転してもらわないとなくならなくなっちゃうんですね
だからそういうのは自然な法則として
そういうもの 別に普通なことでも不思議なことじゃないんだけど
そういうことで入定に入ります
で 心が止まっていても
体と心は一旦停止だから
あの 必要な電波が入ったら心がまた機能するようにということもできます
もし昔ですからね お釈迦様に呼ばれたら
たとえ滅尽定に入っていても
週間滅尽定に入りますよと思って入っても
お釈迦様に呼ばれたらすぐまた禅定が切れちゃって心が活動する
それはお釈迦様の力ではなくて
禅定に入る人が入る前に 1週間禅定に入りますよと
その先にもしお釈迦様に呼ばれたら禅定が止まりますようにということで準備しておくんですね
それからサンガの命令ですね
その 2つぐらいです ブッダの呼び
何かあったら用事があったらすぐ立ち上がってそれに行くか
サンガから何か命令出しちゃえば
たとえ阿羅漢であろうが参加しなくちゃいけないんです
そうでないと別にどったことない
他の人の話はというような
そんなに前もって決める
大体 1週間ぐらいです
なんで 1週間ですかってわかりませんだけどね
一応体の維持は 1週間以上できないという話なんですね
心なしに体は物体だからね
この物体がそれなりに利用しなくちゃいけないでしょうし
まあそれでも一応アビダンマの基本的なところは終わります
まあ一応  2  3ヶ月間ぐらいで終了するように計画立てたみたいですけど
まあ私にはそんなに早く教えるぐらいの能力はないし
だから時間かかってしまって大変申し訳ないんですけどね
だからなぜアビダンマ論かというとね
そうやってどうしても人間には理解できないんですね
仏教で言ってる世界っていうのは
神様の世界とはもう違いますからね
ですから このもののありさまは無常であること
因果法則やら魂やらレゲコンやら実体というのは何の元もないんだと
全ては幻覚であると それからもう解脱をするべきですよと
それしか方法ないんだということを厳密に
論理的に 科学的に説明して納得してもらいたいということなんですね
だから悟りというのはいい加減な宗教的な
ちょっとしたいい加減な気持ちではないんだと
人のいい加減な気持ちではなくて
こういうのはもう具体的なはっきりした科学的なプロセスであると
というもう仏教は宗教的というよりはすごい学問的なんですね
修行自体の それを言いたくて作ったもんですけど
やっぱりこれは古い人々がね
科学学問ない世界でね
いわゆる物質的な科学学問ですね
あまりない世界でできたものだから
科学みたいなものがあったのは全てインチキでしょうしね
インドであったものはね
星占いとかね 人相占いとか
それを仏教では否定しているし
治療の方法にしても 半分治療で半分インチキでしょ
ですからもうお釈迦様だからもうやめましょう
そんなことは ということでね
純粋科学的なものっていうのはね
もうインド人は威張ってるだけのことでなかったんですよ
はっきりと 威張ってるだけ
あれは だから仏教もその同じ文化の中でできたんだから
まあもうそんなに科学とかなんとかとかもなかったのにも関わらず
もう一生懸命このね もうインチキのいい加減な非科学的な迷信だけの世界の中で
なんとか頑張ってこのところを科学的に分析して
存在を科学的に分析して解脱しましょうっていう目的で
飛行機作りましょうという目的ではないんです
暖房を作りましょう 冷房を作りましょう
動く車というふうな現代人が持っている科学とは違うんですね
解脱しましょうと ですから
解脱する前に なぜ解脱しなくちゃいけないかと
そこはやっぱり説得してもらわないと
納得しないと 納得しない人の修行っていうのは
そんなに当てにならないんですね
だから解脱に納得しない人々にとっては社会的な仏教あります
お祭りやらね 徳を積むことやら
行儀よくみんなと仲良くすることやらね
いろいろ祭りあります
で 真理に納得いく人々にとっては
特別に解脱の道というものもちゃんと明確に別々にあります
だから解脱できれば解脱にチャレンジすると
そうでないと徳でも積んでみなさいと
地獄に落ちないようにと
でも祈願希望だけしておきなさいと
いつか解脱しますと 永久的に徳ばっかり積んで輪廻転生ばっかりしているのだと思ったら
それはちょっと危ないんだと
徳を積んだっても一回天国に生まれるかもしれませんだけど
そこで死んじゃったらどこに生まれるかわからないでしょうし
そこで仏教の話を聞けるかもそっちでもわからないし
徳を積めるか積めないかもわからないですよね
その危険性があるんですね
すごい徳を積んだ人がどこかの国の大統領になってしまったら
それは人殺しばっかりしちゃうんですね
それからはね そうすると次はもう地獄にしちゃうでしょうに
だから無意味なんですね
だからせっかく徳積んだんだから
徳を積んだんだからって
ずっと幸福だけの人生
生命ではないんですね
過去世でいっぱい徳を積んで
それですごい頭の鋭くて
ものすごい美しい美女か美男で生まれるとする
抜群のもうすごくこの何て言いますか
美しさで生まれたとする
それからその人は徳を積むんですかね
徳を積むどころか ものすごいだらしない生活するでしょ
みんなにちやほやされたりしてね
だから次は危ないんですね
そういうことで徳を積む場合でも
あのずっと気をつけて
このどこに生まれても知恵があるようにとかね
悪いところに まあ良さ子の信者さんたちは大体そうやって誓願の文章長いんですけどね
やるんですね どこを生まれても智慧のあるところで生まれるようにと
仏道から離れないようにと
どこを生まれても恵まれても
そっちそれに奢れないようにと
いっぱいそれを持ってお布施をしたり
徳を執着しないで徳を積めるようにというふうに
自分の人生設計 祈願として言うんですね
で やがて智慧を開出して悟りますと
まあそれはその通りにいくかいかないかわかりませんだけど
やっぱりそういう風な世俗的な次元もありまして
こうやって厳密にこの出家する人々に悟り目指している道もあります
じゃあ時間になりましたので
この辺で終了しましょう
ありがとうございます